[music]
>> Only time I use notes is in a debate.
But in a debate, when my opponent is
speaking, I have to jot down.
And then I have to put in my
hard disk, difficult. You know, when we
record here,
we put hard disk and then we put it into
LTO drive. LTO drive is archiving.
So, when it goes in the memory, it's
archiving. Yeah, I'm only jotting down.
To retrieve it, I have to take the help
of notes. Unless I don't put in the
long-term memory,
and I don't have the time to put in the
long-term memory. So, when I jot down
points in a debate, that's the only time
I
pick up and speak. For example, if I
have to give comments
about how the participants have spoken,
I I have my marks. At that time, I have
the notes. Now because we want to be in
the same line, I've given you point form
notes. That is the reason I'm picking up
and keeping it. But giving a talk
without notes is the best. If you cannot
do it,
then have point form notes. That's it.
If you have the written text, you will
ruin your talk.
How to give a speech with a written text
is a different technique.
With the podium,
which if time permits,
maybe I'll demonstrate.
Even with podium,
with podium, the lower the podium,
the better it is.
But the lower it is, the more difficult
to read it.
Oops.
If you use a podium, use a sleek
podium.
If you have seen the president of USA
speaking,
on his official, not unofficial,
with the past president or the present
president, you see that they have a base
and a thin, not always, huh?
Not always. Many a time,
they have thin and they have a flat
surface.
So the least is restricted.
So if you want to have a podium, have a
podium which has a heavy base.
If my feet is blocked, no problem.
My shoes are blocked, no problem.
Then have a heavy base and one rod.
Same like this.
And a flat.
The podium will not restrict my talk
much here. But me looking down
will reduce the eye contact, which we'll
do later on.
Here when I'm reading, my face is on top
on the podium.
Important tips.
Body language is very very not a point
form, so I can look on top, but normally
I have to read.
Now, you tell me,
body language
is very, very important.
Body language is very, very important.
Both I'm reading.
So, reading is also a technique. Reading
like that is more effective according to
me.
My hands are restricted. It's not the
best.
I'm only gesturing with one hand.
Sometimes I take on my left hand and
gesture with this hand. Now, when I'm
turning the notes, half my gestures are
gone. Half It's not half, it's more than
half.
Because two hands we can do much better.
My one hand is blocked. So, with notes
when you carry,
when you use the podium,
both your hands are free,
but your look is down.
So, if you cannot give a talk
even
with point form, means you must have a
script written,
then the best is the podium.
And the many speakers who vomit out, and
we will be showing you tomorrow
how some people
use scripts in podium. They have
modulation,
but you can see the impact.
And you have other people who use
podium, who know the technique of using
podium,
which is I'll show you tomorrow. They
are masters.
But again, they're using point form.
They use the podium, they are master
speakers.
But they have limitation, they cannot
memorize like Sheikh Deedat without
notes. That's the limitation. But if the
same speaker
if he would have spoken, for example,
Jimmy Swaggart,
Who has seen Jimmy Swaggart speaking?
Most of you. Does he speak with notes or
without notes?
With notes or without notes?
With notes. Sorry? With notes. With
notes. Does he speak with podium or
without podium? With podium. With
podium.
But he knows the art
of speaking
with the podium.
Very good. One of the best speakers
that I know of
in the world. One of the best, not the
best, one of the best.
Speaker
in public speaking skills
not matter.
Not the best, but
one of the best.
And he's taking care he's been trained.
So, training how to speak on a podium is
a different technique which we don't
want to teach. Because why do I want my
students to be second class? I want them
first class.
And there are multiple benefits which we
know. If you use podium, then not only
in first section you get low marks,
second, third, fourth, fifth class.
And we'll come to it.
What is the benefit of speaking from
memory?
And how it benefits your speech, your
question answer, debates, everything.
And so, you can use a podium, it's not
haram Islamically, but it restricts your
body language, your movement, and the
impact becomes less. If you have to do
it, there's a separate technique of
using it which can minimize the loss,
but not completely delete it. Hope that
answers the question.
Yes, brother Firoz.
Salam alaikum, Dr. Zakir Naik. Alaikum
assalam. Okay, what is your opinions
about like in the competition of world
public speaking competitions where
the participants, they are big they
without the mic stand, they are given
the mic which is attached to their head,
and they move around the stage which
allow more a body language expressions
like what this job done? Because when we
look into YouTube, there's a lot of such
video that talking about how they
attract their audience by walking around
and without being attached to one place.
What is your opinion on that?
As far as speaking with a moving
microphone is concerned, we'll be doing
that
later.
But because you have asked the question,
it is
actually overlapping.
I thought I'll do it in the public time.
Public address when I speak, I'll be
paying more attention.
For
a non-Islamic talk
for
I do agree
that speaking the way they speak, for
example
Do you know which is the best
organization for public speaking?
Can you give me the microphone?
Yes.
Carnegie, New York.
I said which is the best public speaking
organization?
The best public speaking organization
You want to try? Okay, fine.
It's not IRF, huh?
I was going to say that, but then if you
if you exclude that, then it would be
Toastmasters.
Toastmasters is known
You want to try?
The Toastmasters is known to be Dale
Carnegie is different. Toastmasters is
an organization which is an
international organization which has got
branches throughout the world, in many
countries, including India, USA, UK.
I think all the countries you come from,
they'll be having a branch, inshallah.
And they're supposed to be people who
train, etc. And they also have a
competition every year.
World championship, Toastmasters world
championship. I will show you clippings
of that.
Inshallah. But the time is yet a few
days to go.
I thought I'll keep it for that time.
Many a time it will elapse.
And there you do find people using a
microphone. Now, the difference between
that microphone and this microphone is
that
I don't know whether I should I go into
that, but if I go into that, I will lose
the concentration here. I think we'll
leave it for that time.
But in short, I won't go into the
details. In short, the difference is
there when you're speaking, it's a topic
which may be humorous.
It is general topic. Ours is Islamic
topic.
Not that you can't add humor to it.
But it's not topic of fun.
It's not a love story. It's not a
competition of joking.
You can use humor. You can use just in
it, but mainly it is a topic where a
person has to concentrate.
I personally, yes, there are
one or two speakers who I know
at present, two or three who I know, who
do use this, but unfortunately, they
don't know how to
handle the microphone.
How to speak on the stage using a
microphone which comes to your It is
better to hold it there. Normally, you
cannot speak with the microphone. That's
called a lapel microphone.
A lapel microphone, you cannot speak
because lapel microphone is not meant
for speaking in public.
Lapel microphone is meant for recording
for television, which we shall deal in
shaa Allah in public address system.
So, if you want to move and speak, there
are only two options.
Either have a handle microphone.
If you're doing a TV recording without
the public address system, public
address system means
there are speakers
from which the public can hear.
If there's no public address system, you
can use a lapel microphone for a TV
talk, no problem. For a workshop,
excellent, the best.
But if I use a microphone which is a
lapel microphone, known as collar
microphone in layman terminology, and if
I move, there'll be feedback. You know,
you will get a feedback.
Noise coming. Because that is a
different type of microphone. We'll
discuss in public address system. I
don't want to go into details.
>> [music]
>> And the rahim ya
Have me a
>> [music]
>> taco ya
And Karim
I'm in Carolina
And I'll be with you yeah
Because I
will be there
And honey
>> [music]
>> I'm a man of substance I'm a man of milk
and honey and I'm I'm a man of milk and
honey
and I'm
I'm a man of
milk and honey
and I'm
I'm a man of
I'm a man